hi i'm lauren cohan and i'm here today
doing a shoot with JQ my first ever date
was sharing a school bus home and
getting kissed at my bus stop that was
it's hard to top the romance of that my
second best date was in cinema and
before he kissed me eating a bunch of
sweets and so he put sugar all over my
face which was less romantic I'm really
old-fashioned I always think a guy
should pick you up and pay for dinner
and I'm a really generous person but I
like tradition I think it's nice I'm a
big believer in if he's into you he's
not going to keep it a secret and so I
don't chase anything I just sort of let
the universe show itself to me I guess
I'm probably biased I'd say that the
best character on a date in my series
would be Steven Yeun because he plays my
husband and he's also the funniest
and I think that that's the most
important thing about a date I don't
need serious conversation if I if I
spend an entire evening not talking
really about anything but I've laughed a
lot then it's golden